hi I'm dr. Neil singer from AC kinetics
in Armonk New York and I'll be talking
about our use of Wolfram system modeler
and Mathematica and our workflow for
designing AC induction motor drive
controls
i'm neil singer and might would give a
shout out to Ken Pasch you worked with
me on this but I'm going to be talking
about using system modeler and
Mathematica to rapidly you know to
rapidly build Hardware control systems
so basically a little background about
who was AC kinetics so we're an
independent engineering firm we're a
group of MIT trained PhD engineers and
we have about 25 years of working
together and we started out in machine
vibration and control software so we
we've done a lot of licensing over the
years in area visit by residual
vibration reduction motorized equipment
no sway cranes where we control cranes
are handling nuclear materials and other
high cost payloads we also worked on the
hundreds of millions of hard disk drives
doing the acoustics and also the you
know speeding up drives and we've
developed this non-linear optimization
technology and so what we used it is to
do on AC induction motors we said okay
you know induction motors are used
everywhere through industry and forty
five percent of the world's energy winds
up in a motor somewhere so all the
energy produced in the planet winds up a
forty five percent of it winds up in a
motor so we entered into joint
development agreement with koch
industries and and these are some of our
previous licensees and anyway so i'm
going to go into jump into how we use
system modeler in our workflow so first
thing we do is we use as a proof of
concept as a digital twin for our
software verification and then more
recently we're going to show some
equation derivation so here's an example
of a prototype drive this drive is
capable of 700 700 volts and is capable
delivering 900 amps
okay we run it at five horse though
which is much smaller it's a serious
drive so we use system modeler to verify
and so this is what we do is if you look
here in the center there is our C API so
we check out the API and now we can do
is we can verify it with system model or
make sure it runs make sure
we didn't make any mistakes or any
problems before you run it at 700 volts
now take that same code pull it out of
the repository compile it in the
hardware and on an embedded processor
and it will run and that's the idea is
not a single line of code changes we run
it on the on system modeler and then we
turn around and we run it in in the
physical Hardware so to give you an idea
increase the size of my mouse for the
presentation so this is an example of a
model we run in system modeler this
block here is our C code you know you
can't see it here but it's it's our C
code then we have an inverter and a
motor and we can load it up in various
ways so I'm gonna show it if actually
show this in system modeler so here's a
motor system and our software is running
it and we're and we want to do an
efficiency map with this so you know we
run these efficiency maps in the real
world so here I've taken the the model
and I'm pointing this isn't Mathematica
I'd point to that model I say these are
the speeds I want to run these loads I
want to run I wrote this little function
to create a speed load table so here's a
table that was created and then I
exported it to a file and then that file
gets read in by system modeler and
here's here we run the model I can you
know if any way I want to see how long
it takes it runs at about real time so
it's about 45 seconds so I'm not going
to spend the time on it and we pull back
the results so here we do we just load
the results right in from system modeler
right into Mathematica we can plot them
there's our load profile there's our
efficiency profile and now we can do is
say okay well done clicked in the wrong
spot next slide okay so so here we can
plot an efficiency map so I made a
little function here that we use the
same function we use for plotting our
real efficiency maps this is a digital
generated or a or a system modeler
efficiency mapping and see we the shape
of this and this is a real one from
hardware so you can see they're pretty
similar you look at the red curve up
here at the top it looks as the same
shape as one of these and this is a
different motor so it's not exactly the
same but it's a you know just shows that
we can
prototype even a test that we're about
to run this is a real physical test that
we ran it's a on a heart on a hand towel
winder by our partnering company it's
Koch Industries which is Georgia Pacific
so Georgia Pacific this paper roll here
that you see looks like a tiny little
roll it's actually six feet in diameter
so it gives you an idea of the scale of
things here and and there's a 60 horse
motor that runs it this is the load and
chain you know the speed change on that
machine of the 60 horsepower motor
velocity profile and in this particular
machine we saved half the energy okay so
so you can see there's some big
advantages to doing this and and part of
the workflow is developing this in
system modeler like so could we have
been able to do this without developing
it and I think the answer is no I think
we would needed these tools in order to
develop the software and then apply it
so it gave us great you know a very
quick turnaround on our models and on
our ideas another thing just quick quick
show that we're that we're that heats
going right because you're dumping in
twice the energy it's got to go
somewhere well it goes into the
temperature so there's your temperature
right eats up the motor
you're wasting that energy it warms up
the plant it warms up the motor now you
got to get rid of the heat and it's it
reduces reliability or motors so the
heat may be one of the biggest
advantages of this too to too many in
industry because they want to get rid of
that heat so let me give you a little
bit of another way we use Wolfram
technologies in our in our our work this
is our dynamometer so I'll give you an
overview we use a Yokogawa power meter
it's a state-of-the-art power analyzer
there here's our motor it gets
controlled by a test drive we can
command this the loads and speeds
through an arbitrary waveform generator
what we did is and this is kind of cool
we took will from language and we wrote
a vxi 11 driver that talks to the
instruments and so now we control this
entire experiment the entire dynamometer
is controlled through Wolfram language
so it controls the dynamometer the data
collection the visualization it's all
done there the data you know and the
advantage of it
is make fewer mistakes see you throw
away less fewer results because you know
like if the instrument was set up wrong
oh you know a checklist you forgot a
step it you don't have to do that
because the the the instrument setup is
all done through Mathematica we we don't
lose the data because you once you
record the data you're not putting on a
USB stick and the old days we used to
use LabVIEW we'd store it on a USB stick
run it upstairs plug it into another
computer plot it avoid all that stuff we
basically just grab the data plot the
data it's all contained and the work
throws flows through Mathematica so and
there's just a summary of the things
that we can add support so now I want to
show you a new feature of system modeler
it's just come out I'm reusing a
pre-release version so you won't find
this on the shelves but hey it should be
out soon it's running version twelve of
system modeler so but it's a really cool
feature I'm going to show a use of it a
use case so what we can do is quickly
create a model in system modeler and we
can extract the equations of the model
and then we can use those to design a
control or get some insight and load the
controller back into system modeler so
let's just show an example of this so
here we go we're going to connect up you
see we're running version 12 here I told
it what the model I'm running which is
an elevator model that's a really simple
model so I'm gonna jump over to the
elevator model and here it is and so
basically I got an input position
there's a mass here that goes up and
down and there's a spring and another
mass so it's basically just a spring
mass system I made a real simple system
and it's an elevator so if I run this
without any control here it is so I just
give a step as it says it's a ramp but
it's actually that it's a step into my
system and if I run this you'll see what
it does and and this is system modeler
and that's what it does okay so we got
you know give it a step and it goes you
know Springs back and forth so if we I
want to show
of course it lost all my I spent all
this time getting the visuals right okay
well we're almost there I drag this back
in go out a little bit more so there's
my elevator and if I run this you'll see
what happens it'll go do that jump and
then it goes up and down and up and down
and that's the that's the motion that
that you saw there and here's a 3d
animation of it I can you know move that
around and look at it from different
angles which is a really nice feature of
system modeler and anyway so so I do
that and said well that's not very good
control so let's do something better
than that and so what I want to do is I
want to design a controller which gonna
look like this okay so I have a
regulator I have my my system I have
some negative feedback and control it
and then I can put my my my command into
it so let's design it in Mathematica so
next step is grab the model simulate it
and these are all different properties
of things you can do with the model from
from the new version of system modeler
what I'm gonna grab is I'm gonna grab
the equations so wait a minute I missed
a step here we go I missed something
here this is really cool if I grab this
model if you notice here there's
eighteen hundred and twelve equations in
that model because it has all the 3d
graphics built into it so that's a
pretty complicated model so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna simplify it so
I'm gonna run the simplification here
and this thing is running off in missins
cool new feature see zero is eighteen
twelve equations it's applying the
simplifications down to twelve hundred
equations now it's in tells you what
what at simplification supplying it's
down to eight thirty it's down to seven
hundred and something and we give it
another minute seven sixty it's doing a
few more we get an idea of the timing
all this and down to six okay so it's
took 1812
equations and it took you know got rid
of aliases like where you have a equals
B and all that stuff and all these sort
of non relevant equations and it boiled
it down to six equations well now six
equations as opposed to 1800 I can
actually do something with that so let's
go look at it okay okay so so basically
you come back here and we got okay so
here we go there's our equations so we
got six equations there's four
differential equations and two algebraic
equations so you got your got them in
Mathematica we can now do things like
look at the operating point and the
parameter values we can go ahead and put
in the parameters into the equations we
can you know look at where the variables
are in the expression we can look at
inputs and outputs so you have all this
equation available so now let's design
something with it so like I said let's
linearize it and get a state-space model
so like bang I converts it into a
descriptor state space model so that's
what comes out of system modeler
essentially directly so I said well how
do we use that so let's roll down here
and we turn it into a transfer function
and then what I did is I balanced the
model so we had some I'm sorry this is
the the unbalanced model then we balance
the model basically make it a little
more friendly in terms of the like you
know this is exponents ten to the minus
seven and and things like that so we
make it a little more balanced and then
and again this is all posted online so
you can look go through its more slowly
but so then we do is let's design a
controller for it so we design a
regulator first thing we do is we create
a an integrator
and we add an extra state onto the
equation then we we hook up an
integrator because we want to get some
integral feedback right take the error
and integrate it and send that back
around because that's how you're going
to get your control and so we merge the
integrator into the system and it looks
like that and you know I'm I think I'm
okay on time so I'm going to keep going
and then which you you wire it why are
the feedback together so it basically
here's our final regulator so here's the
the lqg
later designed in Mathematica and this
is the regulator we're going to use so
you know using you all built in
Mathematica commands
I want to thank sue bono if you see her
yet okay he's yeah he helped me out with
this as well in terms of you know making
sure we got it got it right and just to
show you we were able to wire the snow
then we say okay let's hook it up and
try it out so we we wire our regulator
to our system and then we wire our
system together and feedback okay you do
a system model feedback connect so we
wire it back and now let's see how we
did so we'd look at the output response
and here's the original output response
which is that you know if you just open
loop step it and then here's the new
controlled response well is that really
what we get let's find out so next step
is we send this back to system modeler
so there I just sent it back to system
modeler if I open up system modeler
right here and I click on my regulator
which you'll see is all these numbers
down here those came right out of
Mathematica okay so I made a regulator
and I sent it back into system modeler
so my my regulator now has all that
stuff I designed in in Mathematica so
now how well does it work so let's go
back and run our model and here's our
model and so I'm going to change this
I'm going to disable this component and
I'm gonna enable in my step that's not
another nice new feature of it's just a
modeler we use anyway and so let's run
this and we run this and we look at the
response and there we go it looks just
like we had hoped you know actually it
looks very much like the response we've
got in Mathematica dicted in Mathematica
right if we scroll down here that
response a little bit overshoot comes
right in and and we get the same
response a little bit overshoot comes
right in and if we want to do be a
little nicer is we can go back here not
back here back here and give it a go
back
to a ramp and reenable this component
okay
actually before I run it let me run show
you just the response of the the other
one the the animation because I think
it's kind of okay sorry about the
scaling here I should have done this
okay so here's you'll notice the step
response is gonna be a little weird
because it's gonna do a little jump up
in here in this part but see how it for
the step response though you sorta did a
jump and then and then that's how it did
the step response now let's actually do
the ramp and you can look at the ramp
response and run this again and you'll
see now it tracks a ramp and the
response is really nice so there you go
so it looks really good and if I look at
the animation we can run that and I had
to go find a nice elevator looking thing
online to put in my graphic I got it
found a 3d model very nice actually I
first had problems cuz that glass walls
to it make in the image building dark so
I guys like anyway so that's so that
shows how that works so now if we jump
back you know so that that's just and so
the idea of showing this was just to say
hey look you can do these designs right
there you know you can take equations
you can then process them you look at
you know oh what happens in steady state
will set my derivatives to zero and
let's look at what the steady state
behavior of the model is I got the
equations and you really can't do that
with other medela implementations where
you actually can can draw these models
right graphically like this and then say
hey what are the equations that are
underlying that model because when you
when you drawn graphically you lose the
equations when you do them everyone you
know most the time we say let's start
with basic principles and start
formulating the equations but you lose
the ease of using the model of of wiring
it together so now you get the best of
both worlds you can wire it together
really easily and then you
get your equations out and you can get
some insight into what you're doing so
let's see I think we're almost done
that's it so we're pretty much done I
kept it on right in time okay so any
questions that's it
[Applause]